ahora vamos a tomar un número en el
sistema decimal y lo vamos a pasar al
sistema hexadecimal ok vamos a tomar el
2000 2000 en su representación en el
sistema decimal y lo queremos poner en
su representación en el sistema
hexadecimal entonces como siempre te
recomiendo que le pongas una pausa y
trata esto de encontrar la
representación hexadecimal de este
número decimal
el chiste aquí es representar a 2000
como la suma de múltiplos de potencias
de 16 así es que de una vez vamos a
escribir por aquí las potencias de 16
tenemos 16 a la 0 es igual a 116 a la 1
es 16 16 al cuadrado es 256 16 al cubo
es igual a 4 mil 96
y estas son todas las potencias de 16
que necesitamos porque 16 a la 3 ya es
más grande que 2000
y entonces lo que hacemos es buscar cuál
de estas potencias es la más grande que
quede dentro de 2000 y resulta ser 16 al
cuadrado o 256 entonces queremos ver
cuántas veces cabe 256 en 2000 y para
eso vamos a usar la calculadora ponemos
2000 entre 256 y obtenemos 7.8 ok 256
cabe 7.8 veces en 2000 entonces el
múltiplo más grande de 256 que cabe
dentro de 2007 por 256 ahora todavía nos
falta sumar el residuo que nos queda así
es que vamos otra vez a la calculadora y
tenemos 2
menos
256 por 7
y nos queda simplemente 208
208 y ya tenemos que 2000 es igual a 7
por 16 al cuadrado más 208 entonces nada
más nos falta escribir a 208 como la
suma de potencias de 16 así es que
buscamos la potencia de 16 más grande
que cabe en 208 y esa pues resulta ser
16 entonces tenemos que ver cuántas
veces cabe 16 en 208 ok para ver cuál es
el múltiplo más grande de 16 que cabe
dentro de 208 y para eso obviamente
dividimos tenemos 208 y lo dividimos
entre 16 y nos queda el entero 13
entonces 208 es 16 por 13 ok y no nos
queda ni un solo residuo entonces te
escribimos a 2000 como la suma de
múltiplos de potencias de 16 así es que
ya nos podemos ir al mundo hexadecimal y
tenemos que recordar los valores de cada
lugar entonces la primera cifra el
primer lugar es el lugar de los
múltiplos de 1 ok
aquí vamos a poner que múltiplo de 1
tenemos en esta representación luego
está el lugar de los múltiplos de 16 o
sea es el lugar de los 16 sets y
finalmente tenemos el lugar de los
múltiplos de 16 al cuadrado o sea el
lugar de los 256 es sabemos que tenemos
7 256 es así es que aquí va un 7 también
sabemos que no tenemos ni un solo
múltiplo de 1 porque no tenemos residuo
entonces aquí vamos
0 y cuántos 16 es tenemos pues tenemos
13 16 es pero no es como que podamos
simplemente aquí poner un 13 a ver cuál
es el símbolo en el sistema hexadecimal
para el 13 pues los dígitos en el
sistema hexadecimal empiezan del 0 al 9
pero después del 9 va a que es igual a
10 b que es igual a 11 sé que es igual a
12 de que es igual a 13
y que es igual a 14 y finalmente f que
es igual a 15 entonces si tenemos 13 16
6 tenemos que buscar cuál es el dígito
para 13 y ya vimos aquí que es de y lo
ponemos en el lugar de los 16 es
acabamos de terminar de escribir a 2000
en la representación en el sistema
hexadecimal y 2000 en el sistema decimal
es igual a 7 de 0 en el sistema extra
decimal